very good representative leishman
good morning joe i'm in peterborough i'm
in the dining room alone
representative hatch let's see him on
the screen he'll have to unmute
i here we go i'm sorry uh i'm home at my
i'm at my home in gorham in the basement
and my charming bride is
somewhere about very good
representative rogers i'm katherine
rodgers i'm in concord in my apartment
there's a maintenance person here doing
some work and my dog
good thank you representative waltz yes
i am uh here and i am in my home and my
husband and my daughter are elsewhere in
the house
i am alone in this part of this house
very good
representative heath good morning um
mary heath
here in the city of manchester at home
my husband
is here but he's in another room um
that's it thank you representative
murray
good morning kate murray is here in
newcastle with my dog my husband's in
the basement
dogs huh rosanna wilder
i'm here in kingston uh my uh wife and
daughter are in the house but i'm alone
in this room
very good thank you uh that's 21.
thank you very much and since i don't
have the uh the list
i'm gonna rely on you or mike to call on
who's
up next when we come to 521
and who's who's scheduled to speak on it
very good uh right uh mickey i guess is
going to uh
inform you of what's going on very good
uh representative i have representative
uh maureen mooney the prime sponsor of
the bill promoted to panelists and she
is able to speak
thank you very much welcome
thank you very much first of all are you
able to all hear me
okay yes thank you
well good morning mr chairman and
members of the finance committee
for the record my name is maureen mooney
i'm a state representative for the town
of merrimack
in hillsborough county district number
21.
i'm the prime sponsor of house bill 521
an act relative to the chartered public
school
annual grant for leased space
i am introducing the bill and i am
wholeheartedly
supportive of the bill's passage
the bill text only changes the figure
of 30 000 in current
rsa 198 colon
15 hyphen little h
little h to the sum of
fifty thousand dollars
please note that the fiscal note
indicates
no impact on state county
or local government
currently there are 29 public charter
schools in
operation in new hampshire educating
approximately
4 300 students
in grades kindergarten through 12
each school is a school of choice
serving students and families in
mission-based
curriculum for students to excel
charter schools annually budget
tight budgets as they do not receive
assistance
from local districts but only through
the state
and fundraising only
three new hampshire charter schools own
their own
facilities with the remaining leasing
space
house bill 521 will increase
the lease aid cap by twenty thousand
dollars
to provide some background and i know
that there
are speakers after me as well very
experienced in this
and have been following it very closely
public charter schools were granted the
ability
to receive lease aid in 2012
but that program was not funded
this may be in part that only the 30
formula in that rsa was mentioned
but there was never a specific monetary
cap that cap came
in the last budget biennium 2019-20
and the governor specifically included
that the annual lease
aid be included not to exceed thirty
thousand dollars
per school in his budget
now as of 2019 that monetary cap is in
place
because local districts and the state
do not give assistance to purchase
facility space
an increase in the maximum lease aid
cap is a reasonable approach
to assist the far vast majority
of students enrolled in public charter
schools
with that i will complete my testimony
and introduction of the bill and i would
encourage this committee to vote ought
to pass
on house bill 521
thank you thank you representative
mooney any questions from the committee
members i see representative
thank you chairman weiler um
representative mooney
can you uh tell me now how many of the
charter schools at lease buildings how
many of them
exceed the 30 000 uh reimbursement
um thank you for that question
representative i do have
a summary of the lease aid from 2021
on another screen here to my left it's
one of the beauties of testifying online
and of that list i see none that have
have exceeded the 30 000. but of course
that was the cap
uh yes
thank you uh chairman weiler
so at this point we don't really have
data about how many
would apply for funding beyond
the 30 thousand i don't
have uh thank you again i don't have
that information
uh at my fingertips but uh
i certainly know that charter schools
are in support of this measure so i
would imagine that
several would be interested in that
[Music]
thank you uh representative weiler could
i ask one more question
one more question thank you thank you
um and representative mooney
do you how much um additional funding do
you anticipate
this would cost the uh in the state
budget
i see there's no appropriation on this
bill
i don't uh foresee
any additional because it would simply
be within whatever
monetary number was allotted for that
lease aid line
thank you thank you representative heath
has her hand up for a question
thank you mr chair and and thank you
representative muni for taking my
question
my question to you is specifically with
regard to
the municipal association and the
feedback that you may or may not have
received from them
it would appear in my own city of
manchester we have a number of schools
that probably will
be vacant um based on some of the
recommendations that that we've heard
from our
planners um there still will be huge
huge costs uh to municipalities
um there's still the insurance costs and
there are um
maintenance and at any number of things
that the
local municipality would still
incur as well as
a possible tax impact in terms of the
property taxes
please
you representative as i understand it
uh it sounds like you're asking whether
or not the munici
i have heard from the municipal
association on this bill and the answer
is no
thank you okay i'm looking to see if
anybody else has questions
uh representative mooney until we
know what we have in the funds our
general
process when bills come to us during the
budget process and to retain the bill
then when we go through the um education
budget
we do our best to include that money
since you know it's an active bill
before us so if there's any way we can
we will try to fund that we'll probably
get some further
as to how many uh will be affected and
what what the costs are likely to be
we'll be able to have the lba look that
up
and so we'll have we'll have more data
when we uh get to the budget and put
money in for the charter schools for
that
so don't be shocked if we retain the
bill
understood thank you mr chairman for
that explanation
very good all right and we have others
uh
mr kane who's who's on to speak
uh representative weiler it's mickey
here um just to answer
representative walner's question um from
information we got from the department
of education in fiscal 21 there were
uh 10 charter schools that were capped
at the current 30 000
statutory level so i just wanted to
give the committee that information and
we do have
um a list we have nine who signed up to
speak
on this bill i'll go in order first we
had donna wells followed by kimberly
lavalley
i do not see donna wells in the um
the attendees so i am just going to
allow kimberly lavalley
in to speak all right kimberly lavallee
you're up
sorry we hear you thank you
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is kimberly
lavalley and i live in mont vernon
new hampshire thank you for allowing me
to speak
i'm testifying in support of house bill
relative to the public charter school
annual grant for leased
space my background in charter schools
is i've started
i'm a founder of two charter schools
currently in operation in the city of
manchester
and i sat on the board of one of the
largest charter schools for
approximately 10 years
so that's three schools i oversee the
financials
for two charter schools right now i've
served as a treasurer for many years on
two different boards
and the difference in the lease aid is
tremendous to charter schools
when you look at thirty thousand dollars
versus fifty thousand dollars
with many charter schools leasing in
commercial spaces
with triple net leases it makes a
substantial difference
to the school i will be submitting
my written testimony on house bill 521
and encourage you to vote ought to pass
thank you so much
thank you is there any questions
seeing none appreciate you being here
thank you for your testimony
thank you all right making the next one
next i have peter bewley followed by
matt southerton so i'm going to allow
peter in to speak all right peter
good morning good morning i'm peter
bewley
i'm a parent of two graduates from the
academy for science design
and a current student i'm a board of
trustees member
for asd and facilities chair
uh committee chair as part of the
board i'm here to testify in support of
uh hb 521 fn
bill to increase the cap on charter
school
lease aid um as kim
and representative mooney have mentioned
that this
is a significant impact to our operating
budgets
we at asd our lease
for the 2020 2021 year is in the
neighborhood of 500 000
um not including taxes um
management fees and other factors so
the increase from thirty thousand
dollars to fifty thousand dollars
uh is a is a significant help
uh and allows us to reallocate uh
operating budget uh
from that lease to uh curriculum staff
and teachers
so again i i am support of this bill
and strongly encourage all of you uh to
uh my wife yes how many students now in
academy of science and design
we are currently about 550 students
enrolled
wow you must be the biggest and probably
the most successful
thank you very much for all you do
you're welcome thank you any questions
from the committee members uh yes uh mr
chairman if i may ask a question
or make a comment i should say um i
should just say that
um i my wife and i are uh
uh pretty heavily involved in the civics
education program we've gone to a number
of schools she's going to mar
many more than i have but we've both
gone on a number of occasions and we
uh made a presentation uh before the
uh uh your charter school in nashua and
i i have to say we both came away from
that
being tremendously impressed i think
that we um
we that were we we were mo the most
impressed by that of
all the schools we've done the students
were just terrific
so i congratulate you on your uh
on your charter school thank you and
i've heard great things about it
okay any questions from the committee
members
i don't see any hands up thank you mr
billy appreciate you coming to us
thank you who do we have next mick
uh next we have matt southerton followed
by amy bewley i'm i don't see her
in there and i know we just heard from
peter i i think there's a relation there
so i'll look for her
after matt is completed there is if i
may
um amy has a conflict and will not be
able to attend
uh she is in support of this bill as
well okay thank you very much you're
welcome
okay so mr southerton is in here now
west matt southerton
welcome to the finance committee matt
good morning mr chairman and members of
the finance committee thank you for
allowing me to speak
my name is matt setherton and i'm the
president of the new hampshire alliance
for public charter schools
we are a non-profit nonpartisan
organization and we
support public charter schools and
charter school applicants around the
state
i am here to testify in support of hb
um as representative mooney described
there's approximately 4 300
full-time students in brick and mortar
charter schools
serving 29 public charter schools across
the state
i just want to go over a couple points
unlike traditional public charter school
or
unlike traditional public schools new
hampshire charter schools do not receive
local or state financial assistance to
build or purchase
facility space of their own so as a
result
as she said the the vast majority of our
schools lease their instructional space
this amounts to a total cost to lease
facility space
i reached out to our schools and mickey
is correct there are 11
schools that met the 30 cap last year
so you would have approximately 11
schools applying if you increase the
funding to 50 000 per year
um and i think that is my last update
for you but we are in strong support of
this
this bill and we hope that you will
approve it i appreciate the numbers
thank you that'll help us when we
get to that bill questions from the
committee
i don't see any hands up or anybody oh
thank you mr chair matt um good to see
you again
um yes matt have you spoken to
any of the folks that um are at the
school district level um about
what this would mean and got their
reactions
i have not i i don't know that it's
germaine to the school districts we have
i believe five
charter schools that leased space from
okay we would we would we would love to
lease more
uh space from school districts if they'd
offered us to us
all right so i just i'm looking for kind
of um input from
uh the municipality organizations but
you haven't had any conversations either
with them
no but we'd love to and if they'd love
to lisa space we'd like that because
then we wouldn't have to pay
property taxes okay thank you matt
i don't see any other hands raised thank
you matt appreciate
being here
okay who do we have next mickey
the next two names i have are alison
fitzpatrick and fiona laurie
however i do not see them in the
attendees list right now
so i'm the next name up is robert best
i'll promote him to panelists and just
remind those who
are attendees and do wish to testify if
they want to raise their virtual hand at
this point i can recognize them in order
thank you mickey and it was mr vest
cute thank you very much for the
opportunity to be here my name is bob
best
and a strong supporter of charter
schools
both with my time and with my money and
support this legislation
i am the board chair at founders academy
i'm the treasurer at spark academy um
and i'm an
attorney in concord that provide legal
services to
one existing charter school and three
that are on the way to being developed
so
i really do spend a lot of my time
thinking about this and i support it
because of school choice
i think it's a fabulous model to
have schools that are designed to
perform and if you don't perform people
will choose something else
and i think that that can do nothing but
great things for students
i support this legislation because when
you start a charter school
your building is your single biggest
expense and it's the hardest thing to
find
um it's very difficult to negotiate with
landlords because they want to make sure
that you've got the ability to pay your
rent um and certainly if you're
acquiring a building there's that
challenge too
and this certainly goes a long way
towards helping and when you think about
how much it helps
the 20 000 increase that this bill
proposes
is almost half the salary of a teacher
at a charter school and so it adds that
much more to the classroom that you can
give back
for twenty thousand dollars um you know
our school would probably be able to
acquire
like a hundred chromebooks for students
to be able to use
um you're really talking about that's
the way that this translates when you
get a little bit of help with your
lease aid it frees up your money to do
other great things that are so important
to the charter school
and to the to the impact on the students
and it's all about their choice and we
have to do a good job
and that's why i support the legislation
that's all i have to say
thank you mr best thank you for all your
work you do first charters
any questions from the committee
i don't see any hands raised
thank you for coming mickey who do we
have next that we can
contact uh the next name that i have
here
uh on the list to sign up ahead of time
was sarah labeouf but i also do not see
her
but i do have amy clark from the
department of education with her hand
raise and
i think would like to speak so i'm going
okay amy clark welcome to finance
community um
hello uh good morning for the record my
name is amy clark
and i am the administrator for the
school building aid program at the
department of education
uh building aid encompasses lease aid
under
rsa 198 15 hh
i believe and i just wanted to just um
i actually didn't sign up to speak i'm
here for technical support if you have
any questions
but i do just want to clarify something
um
this bill doesn't make any increased
appropriation
police aid therefore trapping it at 50
just changes the way that we would
disperse
lease aid so your your schools that are
over 30 000 would get more but then the
ones that are under 30
000 would get less because we would have
to prorate
because we would run out of money if
the total amount of lease aid if we were
at the cap
would be five hundred and sixty thousand
dollars uh the
the appropriation was 500 let me make
sure i got those numbers right
the if we were to apply the 50 000
cap we would be giving out 560
000 however the appropriation
is five hundred thousand dollars
therefore we would prorate
uh what was available to schools which
would shift
the i looked at the list for the schools
that applied
this year that would mean eight schools
would get
less lease aid and 10 schools would get
more lease aid so i just wanted to make
that clarification
perhaps the shift is what you're looking
for i'm not here really to comment on
that
or perhaps you're considering a
increased appropriation
also not here to comment on that but i
am the
uh in charge of the lease aid program so
i'm happy to answer questions if you
have them
uh thank you how would we determine why
some would get less
well if if the appropriation is 500 000
and i need to pay everybody 560 000
people would be prorated whatever that
comes out to be 85 percent
and so those schools um
that because those schools that would
have originally got
the full 30 percent i no longer have
that
because i have to cap a greater amount
so that money has to come
come from somewhere and that money would
come off those schools that their
30 wasn't met
well thank you for that information that
is why the intent
i think is to retain the bill then when
we get to the school budgeting
we can take a look and see if we can put
more in
so that the intent of the bill is
fulfilled assuming we can have the funds
available
to do that so i appreciate you you're
pointing that out to us that
if we don't do anything about that cap
then some will get less which is not our
intent
if we if we retain this bill and intend
to do anything with it
so right thank you for pointing that out
welcome
i see have questions from representative
walner and representative petry
representative walnut go ahead
thank you and my question is
how much did we actually spend
on what was our actual spend in
2020 um
2020 uh for this last year 2021 it was
415 000
um which the appropriation was 500 000.
so i was able to give everybody the 30
and the cap of 30 000. i didn't have to
prorate anybody
so that was 415 000. the year prior
fiscal 20 uh we gave out 200 000
we had to prorate everybody 44 because
the appropriation was only
uh 200 000 that year
thank you representative representative
petrie yeah thank you mr chairman
uh is any of that federal money the uh
was just to prove that what 46 million
is any
part of that can be used against this uh
is that question for me uh
representative um i'm not sure
um unfortunately i'm not um part of the
esser
funding distribution but i could get the
answer for you
thank you appreciate it okay
see if we have any other questions here
seeing none uh thank you miss clark
do we have anybody else mickey that
we've been able to contact
um i don't see any of the names uh as
the attendees that are from the sign up
list
i do see a uh sarah earl who
i do it i did have a sarah labeouf
signed up so i'm not sure if that's the
same so
i would just give the attendees um the
instruction to just raise your virtual
hand if you would like to testify at
this point
or if you're called in to press star 9
and i do have a phone in raised hands so
i can allow them to speak
representative wyler i do not i do not
have a name so they'll have to identify
themselves
thank you very much we'll let that
person in and tell us who
they'll need to unmute themselves which
i believe is star six
good morning good morning my name is
my name is sheila shea my daughter is a
student
at asd which is one of the schools that
are
part of this bill uh requesting the
the funding and i just wanted to say
that i really think it is very much
worth it it's been an
excellent education they operate on a
shoestring
it's in a very uh nondescript building
on 101a in nashua and if you didn't know
it was there you'd fly right by it
it looks like an office building they
don't have a cafeteria
they don't have a gym all those fancy
things that you normally
associate with a school but they do some
amazing things with education
she started her education with algebra
in the seventh grade she's now taking
multi-variable calculus as a senior
with uh the instructions she has gotten
has been phenomenal
and some of the classes she's taking i
think i've had in my
second year of college so it's really
prepared her well
to go into college and i i really think
it's worth
supporting this bill i think a lot of
these schools are doing very innovative
things they meet a need that a little
niche me need that isn't necessarily
in other places and i really hope you
consider that
they're doing wonderful things for our
kids um and that that's
uh that's about it that's all i have to
say but i just wanted to throw that out
there
let you know how how well they operate
with
not not a fancy budget not fancy
classrooms et cetera but they really do
some phenomenal things there
thank you we're delighted to hear of
your success and shake
i don't see any hands raised so thank
you very much for coming to finance
community
you're welcome all right do we have
anybody else mickey
i do how do i read mute i'm sorry
may ask there we go i guess you figured
out how to mute okay thank you
i do not see any other hands raised
all right there being nobody else to
testify
um we have i believe we have this in the
calendar that we can exec
after uh after hearing this bill
[Music]
so anybody want to make a motion like
uh yes i move that we retain
uh 521
okay second by representative hamburger
to retain who was the second joe
petrie patriot okay
further discussion if i might
uh check mr chairman representative
thank you very much
um i believe that with
that it's important that
we retain this bill so that we can look
at
what the governor has recommended for
funding
what kind of dollars we might have
available
and this is of course one
of many issues dealing with
education funding this year and i think
it's important
that division two have time to
look at all of this and try to come up
with
equitable and reasonable funding for
education
thank you thank you any other comments
from any
i don't see any hands raised
we have a motion and a second to retain
if there's no further discussion the
clerk will call a role
on the motion to retain
representation are you all set i am
looking for the
representative uh ober yes
representative seberge yes
representative petry votes yes
representative irf yes
representative walner yes
i'm sorry was it was that yes
yes representative norgren
yes
representative hatch you're muted
yes apologies thank you
representative waltz yes
yes representative murray
yes representative weiler
yes mr chairman the vote is 21-0
21-0 the motion is adopted
and no blurb is required on a retained
bill just a listing thank you very much
now we have also before the committee
the four bills we heard a week ago
the first one being uh house bill 297
everybody familiar with that and i don't
know if we had any requests for any
further information
to come from lba i don't think we did
so like mr chairman
who had a question no mr chairman i
would move to retain
okay representative over mr retained
emmerich seconds and the second was
hamrick emmerich okay
any further discussion i'd like to speak
to the motion mr chairman
you are recognized to speak to the
motion thank you mr chairman
all money bills in the year of a budget
really should go
into the budget therefore this bill
which requires 10 million dollars should
be
retained secondly we heard from mr
donovan
that we would have to work out a better
way to
look at and dispose of the money because
of a bill passed in 2016.
the prime sponsor has agreed to work
with that and has an idea for
an amendment but he like us is going to
be tied up with budget hearings very
shortly
we also do not have revenue estimates
from house ways and means
so at this time we don't know what the
money is going to be therefore i move to
retain mr chairman thank you
seeing no hands we have a motion and a
second to retain house bill 297
the clerk will call a role on that on
that
in that proposal thank you mr chairman
our representative ober yes
representative umberger yes
representative burris oh yeah
we can hear you now okay yes sorry
thank you president petry votes yes
yes representative earth
yes representative griffin
yes
representative edwards yes
representative aldridge yes
representative lynn yes
representative rogers no
representative heath no
representative weiler yes
mr chairman the vote is 12-9 in favor
for being 12-9 the motion is adopted to
retain the bill
and again there is no need for a
court because it's just going to go on
as retained
so the next bill we will head before us
that we've heard
398 is it
398.
and that's a bill from representative
bucco
is there any motion mr chairman
representative ober thank you mr
chairman i would move to retain
i would like to speak to my motion okay
is there a second
okay representative emmerich seconds and
representative
ober is recognized to speak from the
motion to retain yes thank you mr
chairman again this is a money bill
unfortunately this bill should really be
filed in the second year of the biennium
and the prime sponsor puts it into the
first year knowing that we
are in a budget some years we've
retained it some years we have it
as i said we do not have revenue
estimates for house waste and means
therefore it's impossible to know if
it's going to fit into the budget or not
therefore i would like to ask that we
all retain it
so that we have a chance to look at the
budget see what goes in the budget we
the division for eight years have been
very supportive of adding more and more
wastewater treatment into the budget
but it is a pandemic year and i think we
have to be prudent
thank you mr chairman thank you does
anybody else wish to speak
seeing no hands raised i'll ask the
clerk to call the roll on the motion to
retain
thank you mr chairman um representative
ober
yes representative umberger
yes representative graham
yes president of the burris
yes president petrie votes yes
representative emmerich yes
representative irf yes
representative edwards yes
representative aldridge yes
representative lin yes
representative walner yes
representative orgrim yes
representative bucco yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yep
yes representative rogers yes
representative walls yes
president heath yes
representative murray yes and
representative weiler
yes mr chairman the vote is 21-0
21-0 the motion is adopted to retain
house bill 398 and again
no report is required we move on to
house bill 412 this deals with
the uh public water systems as well the
other one was
waste water this one is drinking water
thank you mr chairman this is the last
division one bill
again i'm going to move to retain i'd
like to speak if there's a second to the
motion
numeric seconds okay there is a second
representative
uber is recognized to speak to the
motion thank you mr chairman this bill
has two issues number one
is the money issue and the lack of
revenues which i've spoken to twice
already so i will not repeat
the second issue is that the agency
presented written testimony saying that
this bill
failed to include the staffing needs and
the money to support the staffing needs
to make this happen
so if we can retain this prime sponsor
is a member of
finance so he will be working on the
budget with the rest of us
but if we retain it that gives him time
to work with the agency to work out the
needed amendment
on staffing and the cost of that so that
we can move forward in case we
do not put this into the budget again i
don't know what's in the governor's
budget
frieza v this and it would require some
hb2
amendments as well which we haven't seen
thank you
thank you representative uber anyone
else
does anyone else wish to uh speak on
this bill
seeing no hands i'll ask the clerk to
call the role
on the motion to retain thank you mr
12. thank you mr chairman um
representative over yes
representative umberger yes
representative graham yes
representative burrish yes
representative petrie volch yes
representative emerick
yes representative erf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
uh representative lynn yes
representative walter yes
representative uh norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative hatch yes representative
rogers
yes representative walls
yes representative heath
yes representative murray
yes
and representative wiley yes
mr chairman the vote is 21-0 hurricane
motion to retain passes
and the next bill we have is house bill
i would like to uh make a motion to
retain
623. hamburger moves to retain
my second name representative petrie
seconds
i'd like to speak to my motion mr
chairman president
is recognized thank you very much
uh once again i think that we all know
that we have some issues and
need to work on education funding
and i believe that the best way to
handle this
is to retain this bill and to look at
what what the governor is proposing
also i'm sure that most of you are aware
that the last covid release relief
act signed by president trump
contains 57 billion dollars
for ed k through 12 education
and until such time as we know
from doe what what new hampshire
will be receiving from this i think it's
only prudent
that we retain this bill and work on it
over the next month thank you
thank you anyone else wish to speak on
this
proposal seeing none
the clerk will call wait a minute wait a
minute sorry
representative leishman and then
thank you mr chairman as i think we all
know
all the communities have been hit very
hard
during the covet virus crisis
one of the things i noted during the
testimony when we heard from
representative luna and others the
severe
impact the loss of
education funding
[Music]
will be faced by so many of the
communities and i was just going through
the list that was provided to the full
committee i believe
last week and i thought with interest i
looked at
just some of the members of the
committee because i know the members pay
close attention to
not only state issues but their own uh
communities and
berlin uh to keep them whole if you will
is going to be losing over
two million dollars in state funding uh
other
communities like farmington joe's
community 1.1 million dollars in funding
uh representative earth's committee
uh 1.2 i believe million dollars that it
was
and i i guess the concern is that i
think we should move this bill
forward uh because communities even if
you're a senate bill 2
town and you go back to a default budget
you're going to be losing these funds
which otherwise would be forthcoming if
we move this quickly over to the senate
i don't think there's anything else to
add other than last week i reached out
to the retirement system because i had
learned that
our retirement contributions are those
that the towns and cities are going to
be paying
in this next year are going to be up 20
or more over last year so between that
the retirement increases
uh i didn't see these funds being
restored
in the governor's proposal but i would
hope that we would
not support retain and move this bill
quickly over to the senate
so the senate could act so some of these
towns wouldn't be left out to dry
and knowing that these towns are right
now trying to get their budgets prepared
for this upcoming next year
thanks mr chairman yeah i understand the
uh
the need to get the money in the hands
but i think even if we send it to the
senate
it wouldn't get funded any faster than
if it goes through the budget process
so i don't know as they'd fast track it
either but
we'll see representative walner
thank you thank you chairman weiler um i
would just
i i think that uh representative
lischmann laid out
a lot of the issues that we're faced
with here but right now is when schools
are schools are trying to develop their
budgets
and i think they need some
they need some assurance that um to know
what the state is going to do in the
next budget cycle
and they need to know that we're moving
along with some legislation so
for that for that reason i would vote
against retain
and um try to to move this bill along
so that it can go over to the senate and
obviously there would
would be work done on it in the senate
and
probably in a committee of conference to
come up with
something that would give our
communities the kind of assurance they
need
in order to make their to plan their
sorry thank you um i think 6
23 i'm sorry i have another committee
going to
um 623 does a lot of things
it it gives school districts a two-year
window
with numbers that will support
their budgets it also helps out with
um free and reduced lunch there's an
urgency that we
really need to get this through so i
would please
ask you to move this bill forward it's
essential
thank you representative petry yes thank
you mr chairman
uh yeah speaking of farmington uh matter
of fact i'm on the budget committee
there
and uh the vote the budget will be voted
on next month
but what the school board has done they
froze the budget
uh the part of the budget about about
million to million
two in the budget to uh to foresee any
shortfall
it's probably about two dollars on a tax
rate so
it can be done uh you know it's going to
take some fiscal responsibility
and uh therefore we should retain this
and uh
you know do it the proper way thank you
uh thank you mr chairman um
i'm sorry i thought i had the bill here
but the senate
uh i believe is voting on a
school funding bill this wednesday or
thursday whenever
they're going to have session and that
bill
uh will
come over to the house obviously but it
is uh it's also uh
i guess in my opinion that we probably
should retain this bill
so that we can also combine
our deliberations with
what the senate is recommending and so i
just asked that we
i think i think that overall i realized
that
um the the budgets in some cases
are are being voted on um
but i don't know any school district
that wouldn't be happy
once the budget is passed to be able
to accept additional dollars
which of course they have the authority
to do
if in fact more money than
the comes out so thank you thank you
we're going to see if we have any other
hands up and i don't
see any so if
if we're done with discussion i'll ask
the clerk to call the roll
on the motion to retain house bill 623
thank you mr chairman uh representative
ober yes
representative umberger
yes representative graham
yes
representative petri vocias
representative emrick
yes representative irf
yes representative griffin
yes representative edwards
yes representative aldridge
yes representative lynn
yes representative walner
no
representative norgren no
representative bucco no
rosanna leishman no
representative hatch no
rosenda heath no
representative murray no
mr chairman the vote is 12 to 9.
the motion is adopted to retain the bill
and that was our last business for the
day
anyone else have anything else to say
we will be meeting tomorrow i think
we're scheduled to be in the chamber the
house chamber
to hear the governor's presentation it's
at is it 2 30
anybody call the correct representative
edwards you have your hand up
yes mr chairman thank you for uh
recognizing me i
i i just wanted to let the committee
know uh with a heads up
that uh tomorrow to ways and means i'm
introducing house bill 346 with an
amendment
i believe ways and means is prepared to
execute tomorrow and if they
pass it otp then uh it will probably
need to come to finance
as a second committee bill and i
from my reading of the calendar we have
to vote it out
uh next week so if anyone wants to know
more about it i'd be happy to do it
of course it may make sense to wait
until after weizen means votes
all right i guess we'll have to try to
schedule something before
um the thing next week so i
don't have much time you think that's
the deadline huh
well sir i i
i feel like i'm in my first term when it
comes to reading
things like the the deadlines for second
committees on bills
uh so i would i would defer to the
wisdom that's on this committee
but that's my interpretation uh
maybe somebody in lba can say i think
we'll have more time than next week
yeah so if the bill is in ways and means
now
and it's been tagged as a second
committee bill ways and means would have
to move it along
by the next week's deadline and the
deadline is for ways and means rather
than for us
right and then if the bill does uh pass
the house and get referred to finance
you'd have until crossover time yeah the
second deadline for bills yeah i would
that would be my impression
all right i told you there were smarter
we have a group of geniuses called the
lba
so congratulations i'm glad we had a
good turnout
and everybody's getting better at this
zoom thing
most people were unmuting themselves at
just the right time and muting
themselves while the dog was barking or
the phone was ringing
so that worked out well and tomorrow
how many plan to go to concord tomorrow
well the weather's supposed to be a
little better
anybody going to concord yep several
hours of me going to concord
i'll see you all there we'll be meeting
in the chamber
i think the governor will zoom and
probably matt maylou will
also zoom representative emerick for a
comment
oh you had your hand up i was just
raising my hand to say i was going to be
in concord tomorrow
appreciate it thank you
if there's nothing else i guess we can
adjourn without a roll call
so unless anybody else has anything
urgent i appreciate you all being here
and uh and working this zoom thing
pretty well and especially with the help
of mickey and mike
thank you very much to the lba staff for
expediting this and i appreciate
representing graham and representative
aldrich filling in on the committee
i'm happy that you were able to help us
out thank you very much
for being here all right without further
ado
i call this uh meeting adjourned of the
house finance committee we will meet
again tomorrow
for the governor's budget presentation
thank you all good morning thank you